[Music]  you got a lot of cats everything about  strays  your new friend are you i'm not so sure  if we don't stand up no one will to bat  in the cat it's got a nice ring you guys  are a hell of a wedding  [Music]  selena don't throw your life away don't  worry honey i got nine of them  [Music]  let's play a game  what's black  and blue  and dead all  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  please do not lie  i'm here to unmask the truth about this  city  you're part of this too  how am i part of this  you'll see  the hell are you supposed to be  [Music]  if this continues it won't be long  before you've nothing left  who are you under there  what is the price for your blind eye  i got you  i've been trying to reach you  grows away  [Laughter]